can people change the question may sound
somewhat abstract and disinterested as
if one were asking for a friend or for
the universe but it's likely to be a
good deal more personally and painfully
motivated than that we ask typically and
acutely when we're in a relationship
with someone who's inflicting a great
deal of pain on us someone who's
refusing to open their hearts or can
never stop lying
someone who's aggressive or detached
someone who's harming themselves or
managing to devastate us we asked to
because the one immediately obvious
response to frustration isn't in this
case open to us we're not able to simply
get up and go we're too emotionally or
practically invest it to give up
something roots us to the spot and so
with the example of one troublesome
human in mind we start to wander
outwards about human nature in general
what it might be made of and how
malleable it could turn out to be one
thing is likely already to be evident to
us even if people can change they
certainly don't change easily
maybe they flare up every time we raise
an issue and accuse us of being cruel or
dogmatic maybe they break down late at
night and admit they have a problem but
by morning vehemently deny that there
could ever be anything amiss maybe they
say yes they get it now but they don't
ever deploy understanding where it
really matters we can at best conclude
that by the time we've had to raise the
question of change in our minds someone
around us has managed not to change
either very straightforwardly or very
gracefully we might ask a prior question
is it even okay to want someone to
change the implication from those who
generate trouble for us is most often an
indignant no love me for who I am is
their mantra but considered more
imaginatively
only a perfect human would ever deny
that they might need to grow a little in
order more richly to deserve the love of
another for the rest of us all
moderately well-meaning and halfway
decent requests
for change should be heard with goodwill
and in certain cases acted upon with
immense seriousness those who bristle at
the suggestion that they might need to
change are paradoxically giving off the
clearest evidence that they may be in
grave need of inner evolution why might
change be so hard it isn't as if the
change resistant person is merely unsure
what's amiss and will managed to alter
course once an issue is pointed out to
them as someone might if their attention
were drawn to a strand of spinach in
their teeth the refusal to change is
more tenacious and willed than this a
person's entire character may be
structured around an active aspiration
not to know and not to feel particular
things the possibility of insight will
be aggressively warded off through drink
compulsive work routines were offended
irritation with all those who attempt to
spark it in other words the unchanging
person doesn't only lack knowledge they
are vigorously committed to not
acquiring it and they resist it because
they're fleeing from something
extraordinarily painful in their past
that they were originally too weak or
helpless to face and still haven't found
the wherewithal to confront one isn't so
much dealing with an unchanging person
as first and foremost with a traumatized
one part of the problem when one is on
the outside is realizing what one's up
against the lack of change can seem so
frustrating because one can't apprehend
why it should be so hard
couldn't they simply move an inch or two
in the right direction but if we
considered at that moment the full scale
of what this person once faced and the
conditions in which their mind was
formed and certain of its doors bolted
shut we might be more realistic and more
compassionate couldn't they just would
no longer quite make sense at the same
time very importantly we might not stick
around as long as we often do we should
at this juncture perhaps ask ourselves a
question that may feel at once unfair
and rather tough given how clear the
evidences of a lack of change in a
certain person and hence of a lack of
realistic hope
that our needs are going to be met
anytime soon why are we still here why
are we trying to open a door that can't
open and returning to a recurring
frustration and hoping for a different
result what broken part of us can't
leave a lack of fulfillment alone
what bit of our story is being reenacted
in a drama of continuously dashed hopes
and if we're talking of change might we
one day change into characters who don't
sit around waiting without end for other
people to change might we become better
at sifting through options and allowing
through only those people who can
already meet the lion's share of our
needs in addition might we become better
at deploying a dash of life-sustaining
ruthlessness in order sometimes to leave
those who frustrate and rebuff us we may
need to rebuild our minds in order with
time to change into people who don't
wander for too long if and when people
might change visit our shop to give a
life-changing gift the School of Life
offers a wide range of thoughtful
practical and genuinely useful gifts
designed to help us solve some of the
most common and intractable problems of
life click now to learn more